[Musik]
absurde Vorschriften Bürokratie sind
Steuergeldverschwendung jedes Mal im
Länderspiegel ein Hammer der Woche doch
was ist aus den Geschichten eigentlich
geworden und welcher Fall ist der Hammer
des
[Musik]
Jahres 8 9 10 erstmal herzlich
willkommen beim Länderspiegel wenn Sie
sich wundern was ich ja gerade mache ich
versuche mit meinen Schritten die
Toreinfahrt abzumessen das müssen so
ungefähr 20 m sein und das könnte teuer
werden denn hier in heln in
Niedersachsen hat sich die
Stadtverwaltung etwas ziemlich absurdes
man könnte auch sagen etwas ziemlich
unverschämtes einfallen lassen und zwar
eine
Sondernutzungsgebühr für große
Hofeinfahrten
schon seit dem Frühjahr gibt's in Hameln
großen Ärger wegen einer neuen
sondernutzungsgebührensatzung für
Grundstückseinfahrten wer eine zu breite
Zufahrt zu seinem Grundstück hat soll
eine extra Gebühr zahlen Eigentümer von
Bauernhöfen mit entsprechend breiten
Einfahrten müssen dann dafür schnell mal
ein paar hundert Euro blechen ja für ja
ja ich dachte das ist ein schlechter
Scherz als ich davon das erste Mal
erfahren habe dass war also demnächst
Eintritt zahlt um aufs eigene Grundstück
zu kommen das würden für mich wenn ich
alles so liee wie es jetzt ist 565 € pro
Jahr bedeuten der Hof der steht schon
seit 1842 hier und jetzt auf einmal 2023
möchte die Stadt für was kassieren was
eigentlich schon immer da
ist dezember
2022 beschließt Hameln die jährliche
Sondernutzungsgebühr für zu breite
Zufahrten in Zukunft gilt die Einfahrt
bei einen Familienhäusern darf maximal 3
m breit sein bei Gewerbegrundstücken
sind es 6
m jeder Meter mehr kostet 15 € für
Landwirt Wolfgang benditte wird das
absurd teure Folgen haben für seinen
Traktor braucht er breite Einfahrten 6 m
reichen da nicht denn sein Hof liegt an
einer absoluten
Engstelle ihm droht eine Zahlung von
rund 700 € jährlich einfach mal
so es kommt ja auch keine Gegenleistung
davor es ist ja ein Istzustand was ja
seit Jahrhunderten ist es ist ja nicht
eine Sache die wo wir ein Vorteil haben
und da was für bezahlen müssen von der
Stadt fühlt sich Bauer benditte übel
abgezockt die Stadt Hameln teilt uns mit
die Einführung der Sondernutzungsgebühr
sei das Ergebnis einer intensiven
Abwägung
unverhältnismäßig breite Zufahrten
bedeuten eine Beeinträchtigung des
Gemeingebrauchs es werden also die
Interessen der Öffentlichkeit in
Mitleidenschaft
gezogen im Alltag werden gerade die
breiten Einfahrten dringend zum
Ausweichen vor dem Gegenverkehr
gebraucht das sind für mich nur
scheinbegründung man muss was finden um
das jetzt durchzusetzen dass man diese
Gebühr erheben möchte es ist auf keinen
Fall eine Sondernutzung sondern seit
Jahrhunderten wird es
traditionsmäßig hier so betrieben dass
die Landwirtschaft eben breite
Einfahrten hat und nutzt aber die Stadt
Hameln bleibt hart entweder zahlen die
Eigentümer oder Mauern sich ihre
historischen Einfahrten demnächst
zu ja Sie müssen jetzt 250 € im Jahr
zahlen das ist eine Menge Geld haben Sie
schon mal drüber nachgedacht die
Hofeinfahrt jetzt zu zumauern nein das
ist nicht möglich also wir würden es auf
jeden Fall nicht machen weil es ist
erstmal nicht machbar für die Autos und
Fahrzeuge auch nicht und dann
verschandelt es den Anblick auch extrem
also das ist überhaupt nicht denkbar man
müsste denn in den Sauen Apfel beißen
und das halt bezahlen also die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben sich sich
hier auch in Hameln gegen diese
sondernutzungsgebürge werrt na also das
gab schon relativ viel Aufruhr auch in
den sozialen Medien die Artikel sind
breit geteilt worden die Meinung ist s
eindeutig die Stadt Hamelin macht mal
wieder irgendwie den Bürger zum
Zahlemann und die Leute sind wirklich
sauer ja wenn es darum geht den
BürgerInnen und bürg das Geld aus der
Tasche zu ziehen dann kann die
Verwaltung plötzlich wahnsinnig fix sein
aber ansonsten sie wissen schon kann es
dauern und dauern so waren es im
ostwestfähischen hasewinkel am Ende dre
Jahre bis die neuen Solaranlagen auf
städtischen Gebäuden endlich ans Netz
angeschlossen waren weitere Z also
insgesamt 13 Jahre hat es in Dessau
gedauert um ein Museum zu
sanieren viel Geduld im Gepäck braucht
es bekanntlich bei der Deutschen Bahn
denn das Unternehmen ist ja nicht gerade
für Effizienz und Hochgeschwindigkeit
berühmt so können wir uns in der
länderspiegelredaktion kaum noch wundern
wenn die Bahn immer wieder für
hammergeschichten
sorgt in der brandenburgischen Gemeinde
zeuten wird seit 5 Jahren dieser
Fußgängertunnel erneuert weil die Bahn
das Ding nicht fertig bekommt ist das
Ortszentrum in zwei Teile geteilt die
Anwohner und die gewahbetreibenden
Leiden in zeuten haben sie die Faxen
dicke das ist keine zuj nicht vernünftig
man muss ständig rumlaufen wenn man
rüber will auf der anderen Seite immer
über die Schranke entweder hier oder da
also wir sehen hier in derrae GZ viele
Leute sich beschweren und traurig sind
weil die Umsätze eingebrochen sind
aufgrund dieser Situation Läden haben
geschlossen aber ändern können wir es
sowieso nicht also wir warten und warten
und warten und warten die Bahnstrecke
verläuft ins heuten mitten durch den Ort
deshalb hoffen hier alle dass der Neubau
des Fußgängertunnels schnell und
reibungslos verläuft doch bald nach
Beginn der Arbeiten treten Risse an
diesem historischen Gebäude auf dann
kommt es laut Bahn zu Problem mit dem
Baugrund Wasser trinkt in die Grube ein
immer wieder wird die Fertigstellung
verschoben im zeutener Rathaus hat man
den Glauben an die Deutsche Bahn längst
verloren befinden uns seit 2018 im
würgelegriff der Deutschen Bahn der
ganze Ort leidet drunter die
Ortsentwicklung leidet drunter die
Gewerbetreibenden leiden drunter die
Eigentümer hier die Anlieger es die Bahn
ist kein verlässlicher Partner für die
Gemeinde zeuten die Kunden kommen nicht
von einer Seite auf die andere
und die Ladenbesitzer kämpfen seit einem
halben jahrzehn sparrung ums
wirtschaftliche Überleben es ist einfach
die ganze Laufkundschaft nicht mehr da
die fehlt in diese Richtung Kommtar
keiner weil hier ist alles zu und kommt
keiner natürlich ja bei der Deutschen
Bahn versucht man gar nicht erst das
baudisaster schön zu reden man habe
Verständnis dafür dass die wiederholten
Verschiebungen der inbriebnahme ein
großes Ärgernis sind leider waren die
Umstände nicht
abzusehen ja man wundert sich warum
solche doch eigentlich kleineren
Projekte nicht doch ein bisschen
schneller vorangehen ist es eine
Katastrophe also ich möchte persönlich
hier kein Gewerbetreibender sein um
damit hier mein Lebensunterhalt zu
verdienen es ist also ich find es
jedenfalls ganz ganz furchtbar aktueller
Zeitplan im Herbst
2024 will die Bahn fertig sein
hoffentlich klappt dieses
mal auch in Brandenburg in lüppen hat
die Stadt direkt am Bahnhof diesen
Parkplatz gebaut Pendler sollen hier ihr
Auto abstellen und dann mit der Bahn
weiterfahren aber auf den 105
Stellplätzen herrscht gähnende Lehr kein
Wunder denn der Parkplatz hat keine
direkte Verbindung zu den Gleisen wer
hier parkt muss noch mal 10 Minuten
laufen er ist beschissen es ist wenn man
so sagen darf es ist wirklich es nervt
es nervt einfach und gerade weil wir auf
Pendler angewiesen sind also wir müssen
häufig pendeln dann muss man mit dem
Koffer und dem ganzen Gepäck bis zum
Bahnhof rumlaufen das kann man älteren
Leuten nicht zumuten und das
ist das ist auch nicht
zeitgemäß
2021 beginnt die Stadt mit der Sanierung
des bahnhofsumfeldes neue Fahrradständer
eine öffentliche Toilette der gesamte
Bereich wird barrierefrei gebaut hinterm
Bahnhof entsteht der dringend benötigte
pendlerpkplatz Gesamtkosten 3,4
Millionen
Euro doch seit der Eröffnung sind die
Parkplätze leer der Grund vom Parkplatz
muss man 400 m entlang der Schienen
laufen am Bahnübergang warten und auf
der anderen Seite die 400 m wieder
zurück darauf hat keiner Lust wir
brauchen ein Parkplatz weil der
Parkplatz hier ist permanent voll und
die Leute parken dann drüben im
Wohngebiet also ja aber es ist einfach
nicht gut geplant denke ich ist einfach
totaler Blödsinn also keiner nutzt den
Parkplatz also geplant ist eigentlich
dass die Pendler durch eine Unterführung
auf die Bahnsteige kommen doch die muss
die Bahn bauen und die Bahn lässt sich
Zeit im Lübener Rathaus wirbt man um
Geduld der Parkplatz sei jetzt schon mal
fertig nun sei die Deutsche Bahn am Zug
wir sind da im Gespräch und wir sind
auch zuversichtlich dass man im ersten
Quartal 2025 die ersten maßn sieht
sodass wir 2025 Ende 25 Anfang 26 auch
diesen Bauabschnitt dann abschließen
können diebn schreibt es brauche erst
noch
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen vor dem
Baubeginn Ziel bleibt die Unterführung
so schnell wie möglich fertig
zustellen also ich glaube nicht dass in
dre Jahren W was passieren wird weil ne
ist ja bis jetzt auch nichts passiert
man sattelt do das Pferd auch nicht von
hinten auf nicht also man muss erst den
Tunnel schaffen dann kann man das die
Parkplätze schaffen aber genauso hat man
es hier nicht gemacht und es wird wohl
noch lange dauern bis Pendler den neuen
Parkplatz endlich vernünftig nutzen
können das Schild hier klar kennen wir
alle aber wissen Sie was das hier soll
ja da müssen einige sicherlich schon ein
bisschen nachdenken aber alle Bedeutung
zu kennen wäre auch ein Wunder denn
Deutschland ist die schilderrepublik
insgesamt gibt es über 680 verschied
verkehrschilder rund 20 Millionen sind
an unseren Straßen aufgepflanzt die
genaue Zahl kennt keiner vor ein paar
Jahren hatten wir den Hammer aus dem
Rosentaler Weg in Berlin 26
Radwegschilder auf 500 m Straße waren da
aufgestellt und manchmal haben die
Schilder auch die falsche Farbe wir
blicken auf einen Fall aus Dresden vom
vergangenen August der leider noch immer
nicht zu Ende
ist inen sind stellenschilder bei Bussen
und Bahnen seit Jahrzehnten gelb das
verstoße gegen die Gesetzeslage sagen
plötzlich die Behörden kein Witz alle
Schilder in der Stadt müssen
ausgetauscht werden Stadt gelb muss weiß
unters Haar Kosten allein fürs Material
satte 300.000 € man kann die Straßen die
straßenbah Haltestellen gut erkennen und
deswegen ja ist es kompletter
Schwachsinn ich Ken die schter noch so
früher war in eine normale Stange mit
dem grünen halestellenschild was rund
war und es ging auch
a ich sehe aber schlecht ich habe eine
Brille aber die Schilder habe ich immer
gesehen also ich ich kann es nicht
nachvollziehen die tresner Polizei merkt
irgendwann dass an den städtischen
Haltestellen wohl unrechtmäßige Zustände
herrschen das Haar steht auf gelben
Grund eigentlich müsse das Haar aber auf
weißem Grund stehen da gebe es seit 20
Jahren eine Regelung in der
Straßenverkehrsordnung nun setzt sich
eine bürokratische Maschinerie in Gang
die Polizei sagt im Landesamt für
Verkehr bescheid das Amt weiß die Stadt
an tätig zu werden die Stadt wiederum
fordert die Verkehrsbetriebe auf etwas
zu unternehmen Ergebnis sage und
schreibe 1600 Schilder müssen für viel
Geld erneuert werden aber selbst die
Verkehrsbetriebe wissen nicht was das
Ganze eigentlich bringen soll
die Haltestellen waren nach unserem
dafürhten auch für Fahrgäste ganz gut
erkennbar wir kann mich auch nicht in
Sinn dass es mal irgendwie
Kundenanliegen gegeben hätte wo
Fahrgäste gesagt wir haben die
Haltestelle nicht gefunden weil die eben
nur auf gelben Grün zu sehen war wir
fragen im
Bundesverkehrsministerium nach was das
denn für eine Regelung ist die in Tresen
jetzt zum teuren schildertausch
führt die Thematik der weichenden
Farbgebung von trägertafeln wurde im
zuständigen
bundländerfchausschuss besprochen
hierbei wurde darauf hingewiesen dass
die weiße trägertafel auf Wunsch des
Bundesrates zur Vereinheitlichung des
Erscheinungsbildes eingeführt worden
sei diese Vereinheitlichung halten die
Menschen in Dresden für völlig
unnütz ich weiß nicht was da eine
Verbesserung sein soll das Haar steht
genauso in der Mitte ob auf weißen oder
gelben Untergrund hat und jeder weiß ha
ist eine Haltestelle ich glaube die
Arbeit die sich die Menschen machen die
könnte auch besser investiert werden und
auch das Geld bis jetzt sind erst gut
300 Schilder erneuert worden es gibt
also noch viel überflüssiger Arbeit zu
tun für die
montagetrups und in Schönau im
Schwarzwald sorgen diese Schilder für
großen Ärger und das seit Jahren denn
sie stehen mitten auf dem Schulhof und
teilen diesen auf unfassbare Weise in
zwei
Teile hier in Schönau führten mitten
über den Schulhof des Gymnasiums eine
Straße ihren Pausenhof müssen sich die
Kinder mit vorbeifahrenden Autos Teilen
geschützt werden sie notdürftig durch
einen Bauzaun die Schüler fühlen sich
eingesperrt man würde gerne dass man
sich frei bewegen kann und dieser Zaun
nicht immer im Weg steht natürlich geht
der Zaun so weit dass er uns schützt vor
den Autos aber dass dann die Autos
durchfahren dürfen und wir eben hinterm
Zaun sind das ist eben das was uns dran
stört man hat halt eben nicht den Platz
den man gerne hätte und es ist schon
nicht so leicht hier zu Spielen 2006
wird das Gymnasium vergrößert nun aber
ist der Pausenhof zu klein der
Rathausplatz gegenüber wird kurzerhand
zum zusätzlichen Schulhof erklärt
eigentlich ist die Erweiterung eine
feine Sache wenn jetzt die Talstraße
nicht mitten durchführen würde ein
unmöglicher Zustand aber seit 17 Jahren
findet die Stadt keine
Lösung zuletzt lehnte der Stadtrat im
Frühjahr eine Sperrung während der
Schulzeit ab statt die Autos zu
verbannen werden nun die Kinder hinter
einem Bauzaun eingesperrt an den Autos
vorbei geht es hierdurch von einem
schulhofteil zum anderen der
Schuldirektor fordert die Autos müssen
weg die Lösung liegt auch für uns auf
der Hand dass eben hier der
Pausenbereich der durch die Straße
unterteilt wird dass der einfach zu
einem geschlossenen Pausenbereich wird
in der Zeit in der wir Schule haben aber
der Stadtrat will keine sparung absurd
denn die Straße braucht niemand es gibt
hier zwei Straßen und dort zwei Straßen
auf denen man ganz bequem ins
Stadtzentrum fahren kann die über ein
Schulhof braucht eigentlich niemand die
meisten Ratsmitglieder aber lassen das
nicht gelten es hat natürlich
verschiedene Hintergründe da sind Ängste
dabei man kommt nicht mehr zu den
Geschäften ich selber sag man kommt zu
Geschäften weil es viele Straßen jetzt
gibt Esen Ängste da gewohntes aufzugeben
da steht mal als Bürgermeister
einigermaßen machtlust da aber dann muss
man das anerkennen was in dem
demokratischen Prozess entschieden
worden ist die Eltern haben die Nase
voll zusammen mit den Schülern wollen
sie den Beschluss des Stadtrates kippen
sie sammeln Unterschriften für einen
Bürgerentscheid eingesperrt wieso im zo
also das findet jetzt keiner gerade cool
da braucht auf alle Fälle eine andere
Lösung 15 Oktober in Schönau wird
tatsächlich über den Schulhof abgestimmt
die Wahlbeteiligung ist hoch und das
Abstimmungsergebnis
eindeutig von den 943 Stimmen entfielen
auf ja 704
Stimmen Schönau bekommt endlich einen
ungeteilten
[Applaus]
Schulhof hier der Absperrzaun mitten auf
dem Schulhof aber Stefania eure Proteste
haben sich gelohnt es gibt jetzt gute
Nachrichten ja die Straße wird temporär
gesperrt wir haben unser Ziel erreicht
und darüber sind wir auch glücklich das
heißt ja Mara im nächsten Jahr habt ihr
dann einen großen freien Schulhof habt
ihr schon Pläne wir haben sehr viele
Ideen weil wir jetzt halt eben die
Möglichkeit haben zu spielen wir denken
über Fußballfelder nach aber auch
allgemein paar Spielgeräte damit auch
vor allem die kleinen bisschen mehr
Platz haben um sich auszutoben in der
Pause uns wird gezeigt dass ich unser
politische Engagement gelohnt hat auch
wirklich und das wurde belohnt dadurch
dass unser Pausenhof 4 vergrößert wird
und dass wir den ganzen Raum bekommen
damit man die Pause auch als Pause
nutzen kann und nicht als Stehplatz
macht die Pause auch wieder mehr Spaß
genau danke schön wir im Länderspiegel
berichten ja häufiger darüber wenn
einzelne Bundesländer gute Ideen haben
also wenn sie neue andere Wege gehen
etwa in der Schulpolitik oder bei der
Energieversorgung aber leider Bremsen
sich die Bundesländer häufig gegenseitig
aus zum nach ihrer Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wir etwa im Streit um die
kitaitapätze zwischen Hessen und
Bayern in bräuberg in Hessen bietet der
gemeinnützige Verein mäusebande zusammen
mit der Stadt kitaabreuung für
Kleinkinder an weil dieser städtische
Neubau nicht fertig wird haben 25 Kinder
im benachbarten mömmlingen Unterschlupf
gefunden mömmlingen aber liegt 200 m
hinter der Land gr enze in Bayern
deshalb weigert sich Hessen etwa 116 000
€ Fördermittel für seine Kinder zu
zahlen händering werden überall Plätze
gesucht wir haben eine Möglichkeit
geschaffen und werden jetzt im Prinzip
dafür bestraft dass wir die Möglichkeit
geschaffen haben nur weil es an der
Landesgrenze scheidert unmenschlich
finde ich einfach unmenschlich ich finde
wir sind dringend auf diese kitapätze
angewiesen Ende 2022 ist klar der Verein
mäusebande braucht für zwei Gruppen ein
Ausweichquartier die bislang genutzten
Container sind marode und der städtische
Neubau wird nicht rechtzeitig fertig
Nachbarschaftshilfe kommt aus mömmlingen
hier finden 25 Kleinkinder samt
Erzieherinnen übergangsweise ein Obdach
in der dortigen
Kita mömmlingen liegt direkt hinter der
Landesgrenze in Bayern also werden
hässische Kinder von hässischen
Fachkräften in Bayern betreut so geht's
nicht meint das Land Hessen denn der
Einrichtung fehle eine hessische
Betriebserlaubnis die zugesagten
Fördergelder werden nicht ausgezahlt für
den Verein ein Schock mal wir kämpfen
seitdem um die Gelder die uns ja
eigentlich zustehen weil es sind
hässische Kinder und die werden hier
betreut in Bayern und wir kämpfen nur
noch darum das heißt immer Land will
irgendwie irgendwas tun für Kinder und
Familien und die Bildung und es passiert
eben nicht das hässische
Sozialministerium teilt uns mit man habe
den Fall in Sachen Fördermittel geprüft
aber die Betreuung der Kinder findet
außerhalb unseres Hoheitsgebiets statt
daher lag die Entscheidung nicht bei uns
sondern in
Bayern das bayerische Sozialministerium
wiederum verweist darauf dass es sich um
hässische Kinder handele eine Förderung
könn es nur geben wenn es sich um Kinder
handelt die im Gemeindegebiet ihren
gewöhnlichen Aufenthalt genommen
haben ein föderales fördermittelf Fiasko
denn die Kinder fallen durch alle rase
ich find es unfassbar dass die Behörden
da es allen Beteiligten so schwierig
machen den den Betreuerinnen den Eltern
und V allendingen den Kindern die sind
wahrscheinlich selber nicht betroffen
denke ich und sitzen vielleicht am
Bürotisch rum und entscheiden das dort
letzter Stand im Streit um Geld und
Kinder Bayern hat rund Dreiviertel der
strittigen Summe an die mäusebande
überwiesen Hessen bleibt weiter stur
und dann wiederum funktioniert die
Zusammenarbeit über Ländergrenzen hinweg
sehr gut man könnte auch sagen zu gut
mit unserem Nachbarn Österreich lautet
die Devise mein Müll ist dein Müll
abfalltourismus hat
absurdum im Landkreis Ravensburg wird
fleißig und vorbildlich Biomüll
gesammelt
entsorgt wird derbe nicht etwa in
Deutschland sondern im benachbarten
allberg in Österreich und um den irsinn
komplett zu machen wird künftig der
Biomüll aus vorallberg in den Landkreis
Ravensburg gekart es ist bekloppt also
es ist jeder normal denkende Mensch
wurde sagen sowas macht man nicht die
Umwelt wird wieder belastet für
eigentlich nichts also ein LKW fährt hin
einer fährt zurück was ich jetzt weiß
halte ich das für ein großen Unfug und
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen das
intelligente Leute Verwaltungsleute so
Unfug
fabrizieren 2013 schreibt der Landkreis
Ravensburg die Entsorgung seines
biomülls europaweit aus das günstigste
Angebot macht ein Unternehmen aus
vorallberg nach EU-Recht muss es den
Zuschlag bekommen seitdem werden Jahr
für Jahr 10 000 Tonn Biomüll von
Deutschland nach Österreich
transportiert 2022 schreibt der
Gemeindeverband vor allberg die
Entsorgung seines Bio müls aus dieses
Mal kommt das günstigste Angebot
ausgerechnet von einer Firma aus dem
Landkreis Ravensburg die Folge künftig
werden 18 000 Tonnen Biomüll aus
Österreich nach Deutschland kutschiert
im rabensburger Kreistag schlägt das
ganze hohe Wellen der
biomülltourismus zwischen dem Kreis
Ravensburg und dem Land vorerberg in
Östreich ist doch ein Stück aus dem
Tollhaus das ist ökonomisch unsinnig und
ökologisch
dlich sowohl der Gemeindeverband
vorallberg als auch der Landkreis
Ravensburg verweisen auf geltendes
EU-Recht man habe nicht anders
entscheiden können den Zuschlag hat der
Bieter mit dem wirtschaftlichsten
Angebot erhalten Nationalität und
Herkunft des Bieters dürfen dabei nach
dem euvergaberecht keine Rolle
spielen
abenteuerlich Biomüll der untermich
tausende Kilometer durch die Gegend
gefahren wird stellt den Namen Biomüll
auf dem Kopf ist Quatsch ganz große
Quatsch auf jeden Fall mal ist es nicht
umweltfreundlicher auf gar keinen Fall
und also wenn alles wieder auf die
Straße verlagert wird ist es nicht der
richtige Weg ein Gespräch aller
beteiligten Behörden und Firmen brachte
keine Lösung jetzt will der Landkreis
Ravensburg fürs Jahr
2026 neue ausschreiben solange wird sich
das biomüllkarussell wohl noch munter
weiterdrehen
alles unfassbare hammergeschichten aber
oftmals ist die Berichterstattung im
Länderspiegel ein erster wichtiger
Schritt gut nicht immer gibt's ein Happy
End aber häufig tut sich was was genau
da schauen wir uns mal gemeinsam an in
unseren hammergeschichten
nachgehakt im Juni
2022 berichteten wir aus dem bayerischen
Lonnerstadt über die Tücken der
Energiewende unter dieses Windrad wollte
die em eine Solaranlage bauen das ging
aber nicht denn in einem Gebiet in dem
Windkraft genutzt wird darf angeblich
nicht auch noch eine Solaranlage stehen
es ist ein Stück weit typisch deutsch
also kennt man ja die Bürokratie das
muss man nicht ganz nachvollziehen
Regina prmann die Bürgermeisterin von
Lonnerstadt wollte das nicht hinnehmen
und kämpfte für die Solaranlage und siee
da inzwischen sind die bürokratischen
Hörden gefallen der Freistadt Bayern
interpretiert das Gesetz jetzt
nachdem dann die
Fernsehberichte gelaufen sind im Juni
war es dann wirklich so dass dann eine
Maschinerie in Gang gekommen ist man hat
sich wirklich bemüht dieses Problem zu
lösen ich glaube das Problem war vorher
einfach nicht
bekannt im nächsten Jahr werden sie in
Lonnerstadt dann auch Solarstrom direkt
unter dem Windrad
produzieren im Juli 2022 berichteten wir
aus Wuppertal über das städtische
Parkhaus kogarten obwohl es damals schon
seit einem Jahr fix und fertig saniert
ist wird es nicht eröffnet der Grund die
Stadt hat kein Betreiber satte 4,1
Millionen investiert aber niemand darf
drin parken dann habe ich mir überlegt
jetzt rufe ich mal beim Fernsehen an
dann kam sie und dann ging es Schlach
auf Schlach dann war die Presse voll
davon und es kam Bewegung in das Thema
jetzt hat die Stadt endlich einen
Betreiber gefunden und das Parkhaus ist
regulären
Betrieb Stuttgart Oktober
2022 der Gastronom Band Kreis
verzweifelte an der Sturheit der
Bürokratie in der Küche seiner Weinbar
sollte damals längst ein Koch aus Peru
stehen und peruanische Gerichte kochen
weil das Restaurant aber kein
peruanisches Ambiente besitze so die
Behörden bekam der Koch kein Visum und
dürfte nicht nach Deutschland kommen das
sitzt irgendjemand hinterm Schreibtisch
hier Deutschland der entscheidet über
peruanische Kultur wie das auszusehen
hat wahrscheinlich fehlt ihm der Typ mit
der Panflöte als ich der Länderspiegel
einschaltet macht die Bundesagentur für
Arbeit eine Rolle rückwärts Panflöten
und Poncho braucht nun plötzlich keiner
mehr rfael Montero bekommt seine
Arbeitserlaubnis er darf nach
Deutschland einreisen und in Stuttgart
Kochen Stuttgart gefällt mir sehr gut
mein größtes Ziel ist
enen die peruanische Küche ner zuingen
und ich bin sehr froh dass ich diese
Möglichkeit bekommen habe zu
arbeiten jetzt sind alle glücklich über
dieses unerwartet tolle Ende dank des ZF
länderspiegels der sich dessen
angenommen hat sonst wäre nichts
passiert wir haben zufriedene Gäste die
können wieder die peruanischen
Spezialitäten
genießen und am Ende unserer letzten
Sendung in diesem Jahr bin ichagen
irgendwo im Nirgendwo hier im schönen
schabo in Meklenburg gibt es vor allem
viele Kühe und die stehen kein Witz auf
der worldwide Wiese denn hier unter mir
liegen tatsächlich Glasfaserkabel die Q
2.0 braucht schließlich ordentliches
Internet oder nicht ja hier könnte er
tatsächlich vergraben sein der Hammer
des Jahres
2023 in scho in Mecklenburg Vorpommern
wdenas Kabel verlegt der Ort soll
schnelles Internet bekommen doch diese
abzweigernd Dorfstraße sorgt bei den
Anwohnern für Erstaunen hier kommt knapp
1 km Breitband direkt neben einem
Feldweg in die Erde die Leitung führt
ins Nichts der Anschluss endet an einer
Kuhweide ja das ist viger Quatsch
Nonsens da wohnt keiner und sind nur
Kühe laufen darum und das Kabel wurde
gelegt warum auch immer keiner weiß es
vielleicht ist die neue Zeit so dass die
Kühe unbedingt Internet brauchen
ja Kopfschütteln einfach nur
Kopfschütteln da fragt man sich was soll
das
Ende März wundert sich ein Anwohner
warum auf dem Stillen Feldweg neben
seinem Haus kräftig gebuddelt wird lutka
Westfall fragt die Arbeiter und bekommt
die Auskunft hier soll ein Breitband für
schnelles Internet hin lutke Westfall
ist sofort klar das muss ein Fehler sein
er informiert die Behörden und auch die
kommunale Betreibergesellschaft den
staatlich geförderten Ausbau ins Nichts
will er verhindern und habe eben dann
nur die Antwort bekommen ja aufgrund
Datenschutz kriege ich keine Auskünfte
habe dann noch mal nachgehakt aber alle
seine Mails und Initiativen laufen ins
lehere das Glasfaserkabel wird unbeirrt
weiterverlegt die Meinung des Bürgers
ist egal der der vor Ort ist und sich
auskennt hat trotzdem keine Ahnung das
was der Plan sagt zählt die Gelder sind
freigegeben und damit wird's realisiert
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste wir fragen
im Kreishaus von Parchim nach ob das
neue Kabel im Feldweg wirklich dahin
gehört der Kreis räumt den Fehler ein
bei der Feinplanung habe es eine
Änderung gegeben dem Tiefbauunternehmen
muss nach unserer Recherche der
veraltete Plan übergeben worden sein was
erst durch die mediennachfrage
aufgefallen
ist dabei hätte der peinliche Fehler
viel früher bemerkt W K wenn die
Verantwortlichen auf die Dorfbewohner
gehört hätten also es wurde darauf
aufmerksam gemacht und trotzdem W es
nichts passiert und ja das sind alles
unsere Steuergelder wie gesagt das
verpufft und das wird so hier gemacht ne
weil sinnlosen Kram und im Grunde
genommen ist es traurig sage ich mal
dass sowas überhaupt passiert sag ich
mal besonders bitter anders als die
Kuhweide werden manche Häuser in scho
nicht ans Glasfasernetz angeschlossen
aber die Kühe am Dorfrand haben jetzt
eine Weide mit
Breitbandanschluss Wahnsinn und wenn
auch Sie eine hammergeschichte für uns
haben sie wissen ja dann schreiben Sie
uns eine Mail an
hammer@zf.de oder per Post an ZF
Länderspiegel in
55100 me wir gehen auch 2024 den
behördenirsin wieder auf den Grund also
kommen Sie gut ins neue Jahr wir freuen
uns auf Sie bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]